13 year old Milo is one of around 300
000 people in the UK living with
Tourette's syndrome
controlling his ticks could soon be
easier thanks to a new device created by
the University of Nottingham
and that's electrical stimulation then
acts on the individual's brain in
training their brainwaves
one like a watch results of a clinical
trial of the device have just found it
reduces the number of ticks by 25
percent
it doesn't just help when you've got it
on it does but it also helps afterwards
for about an hour so for example if I'm
in cinema and I need to tick or the
theater room something like that where I
don't really want to disturb people I'm
just put it on and then I mean if I put
it on for 20 minutes or so then I'll
that's probably 80 minutes because it
works about an hour afterwards as well
for some reason
Milo was among 121 people with
Tourette's who tested the device for a
month which showed the severity of ticks
was also reduced
the Prototype engages the patient's
peripheral nervous system by sending a
series of electrical pulses from nerves
found in the user's wrist
those signals connect to the part of the
brain which is responsible for
controlling ticks
using a process called median nerve
stimulation the pulses interrupt and
prevent the ticks from happening
the device already has a touch of
celebrity Lewis Capaldi contacted the
team inviting them to a gig so he could
test it out the university said it had a
massive effect on the singer who has
spoken openly about having Tourette's
its creators say the device could
provide an additional treatment to
medication
what patience said to us they wanted
was a means of controlling their ticks
on demand when they needed it so they
necessarily want to be cured of their
ticks they see it as part of them but
what they wanted was that
going through the airport in a job
interview at school during an exam they
wanted to be able to have some control
over when and where they were ticking
For Milo and thousands of others this
could be another way to improve their
quality of life the team behind it hopes
the device will be available through the
NHS by 2026. damn Whitehead Sky News